hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Blair which we've
got a tree all we have to do is gather
some branches simple right I'm gonna pet
my dog before I do such a thing because
just give me a second there buddy pal
friend i'ma just petting the dog okay
you fixed my camera you sure did you
know you sure did um I don't know why I
need branches but I'm starting to think
that uh yeah I can't believe it either I
didn't know I had a choice yeah one one
when did I get one and now tough for
these things to break Oh
oh boy oh that's not good Oh gross what
what hey psycho what the hell is this
this thing bleeds I think so yeah okay
all right don't be silly trees don't
bleed it sure seems like this trees
bleeding all right Bob hey where you at
come here stay close we got to go to the
trail for some reason it seems like a
good idea I don't want to know what he's
marked to these trees with that seems to
be glowing in the dark but I'm just
gonna assume it's piss hmm
I don't like the ominous noises that I'm
hearing Oh what my eyes deceive me or
did I see something I definitely saw
something I so saw something oh you
cannot fool me I saw something oh yes
[Music]
did it miss no I'm not well you wanted
me to follow the trail so there's not
much else I could do no no I don't know
I do not actually funny thing is I don't
I see you very clearly see you oh well
that's that's not right that's weird
that's a little bizarre I don't know why
that's happening
now that now the games really certain
lives for me it's so weird cuz I like I
actually think my mind's playing tricks
on me I'm not actually sure what's real
and nots real hello no nothing okay
everything's you all did you come from
where the weight where'd the wall go
there was was a wall here why can you
keep singing that body I'm really
enjoying it such a good song don't worry
about it but don't worry about it woah
it's ok it's ok it's ok good boy it's ok
it's ok
now while a li la la la li little lu
what's up with the white paint on the
trail goes that way but there's as white
a lot of white goop on these maybe I
should follow these instead seems like a
good idea what what's up oh okay you're
okay
ho there hey Chico these photos what are
they who are these people so what
happened to them and be nosy okay so
that just led to that well that was good
I'm glad I found that that's that's good
okay I got to get back now to the trail
wherever the trail is whoa
hi a tree I say hi to the trees
sometimes just so happened that that
tree looked like a person tracks in here
yeah by this tree that looks weirdly
like a person who should good boy who
gets your pet who's your good boy good
job you show good you do good boy good
boy
I'm gonna give oh oh okay that's that's
change somebody call the fire alarm
somebody better alarm the fire fire
alarm needs to be LARM do it where's the
fire alarm okay I'm assuming the fire
fires gone I guess someone called fire
alarm yeah I know maybe
[Applause]
that doesn't make any sense okay all
right you should go boy use a good ball
found the stag it's dead
okay well you know I seem to be a bit
too agreeable about all this I just seem
to be a bit too like yeah okay why not
can you see me what now
have your way [ __ ] nutcase
uh I'm just way too agreeable here I am
and I had that ready to go by the way I
want to mention that that was ready
Wow you only sent he'll get as my own uh
the only thing I'll get in my own I know
this a bowl there you go I guess
bullies buddy wait you're not afraid of
it hey can I call my apparently wife
there call my wife are Josh listen
thanks we're weird here currently
unavailable
okay good figures Jess there was no beef
hey uh uh
I was hoping I'd get to talk to you one
more time there was no variable because
it wasn't meant to be
story of my life huh listen that thing I
was gonna tell you once I got back well
looks like I might not get that chance
please understand I'm not giving up I
just need to see this through I have to
but in case you don't hear from me again
that one mutant mailbox full
you was the best thing that ever
happened to me
I'm sorry I screwed it up I wish I can
fix it I wish we could go back to the
way things were I wish I was good enough
I love you Jess
okay all right guess that's the end of
that not the whole always will and
goodbye part but hey love you love you
something's not right something doesn't
add up
the only sniff filled get is my own I'm
onto you just like bullets onto this
trail I'm onto you I'm onto you
something's going on here something
right or something right
you're good boy hey listen music good
boy you good boy
you's a good boy he was a good boy oh
you too good boy
who's your good boy Oh you's a good boy
all right what what's up what you got
boy hey whoa where you going oh boy yes
not that curious go in it I have to go
in the hole it's not really a mystery
here go on boy wait no no that's that's
not what I
no no no no no no no no no no no where's
that dog bullet huh that's hell I didn't
want that you son of a [ __ ] oh there
you are oh you okay you all right
why are you glowing right now you
weren't going what's going on
I have to do something listen it's all
right sorry I need to do that I'm sorry
I didn't think it was gonna happen
listen you get another treat you get I
got one last treat for you buddy where
you going hey buddy where you going
honey where you going I got a treat for
you if you want it
more power trick question same person
talking before this is over I'll make
you pay for what you did what again
[Applause]
so your only solution was to just give
up I don't like it I thought you were
protecting me for something I didn't
think you were just being a dill weed oh
you say jump I say how high oh yeah
whatever oh when you say punch when you
say don't punch me I'll say well I know
I will keep punching you what's gonna
happen
good boy hey let me know you see your
good boy who's a good boy
Oh would you go hole ooh I don't like
the look at this buddy
no one bit I wasn't looking at that I
was looking at the hole
so what is it another body yeah I guess
why my hands beat up oh cool
perfect III don't understand perfect
what
oh [ __ ] you no no I will not kill bullet
yeah it should have drawn one long ago
I'm not doing this anymore
stop hiding behind a child you coward
well it shouldn't have given me a wait
no I need can I have that why did I
throw away the gun hey wait a minute
that's that's impossible but no what
what what bullet bullet bullet what
bullet where are you bullet Oh bullet
bullet bullet I see people getting down
there
wait up bullet get down here I go hold
on boy I am coming bullet bullet I've
got it free throws don't move buddy
that's gonna be fine let me just die
yeah yeah there you go
oh I've gotta free too much scraps from
the table go tree with your name on it
I'm gonna have to take longer walks
buddy all around the block I'm not
kidding whoever you are don't worry
buddy I would never let you go not in a
mozillian years not in a megalo million
years I would never let you go not not
even not even close not even ever in a
history of forever would I let you go
bullet you are my friend you are my boy
you're so sweet and so handsome you're
the bestest sweetest and to miss dog
there ever was you're gonna get all the
treats you're gonna get so many preacher
cookies so many pets oh you're gonna do
so good oh you such okay okay it's okay
use your good boy I will get you treated
up gonna get you fixed up like nothing
you're gonna eat nothing but ice cream
you go you're gonna just sit around you
got toys you can have a bed made of toys
you just gonna have everything spruced
up
oh crap no please bullet it's okay hey
bullet listen no matter what no matter
what I'm here for you I'm right next
year I got you I don't care if I have to
beat up a Blair Witch with my own
[ __ ] I'm not letting you go buddy
even if this game I'm getting real meta
about this even if this game pulls a
supreme dick move and decides that
something's gonna happen that's not the
reality that happens because I would
punch through the veil of reality to
make sure that you're okay bullet I
would karate chop a hole in between our
universe is to make sure that you are
loved in a warm bed in a and a lovely
forever home
I would make sure that you would
eternally be good forever no shoo shoo
shoo she's okay he's okay it's okay with
me buddy it's okay it's all right don't
you worry about a thing don't you worry
don't you worry about a thing
Wow we werewe ass I can't read that oh
don't worry it's okay you're okay I
don't care if I had to walk until I
collapse from exhaustion lie yeah I'm
pretty sure there's lies going on here I
think it's doing the thing where it's
looping the chasm over and over again
but I don't care I will sit here all
goddamn day
I will glue my finger to this w key I
will not let this dog go because there's
no way in hell I would ever do that I
don't care what you say game listen game
if you think for a second that I will
not go all night with this [ __ ] if you
think for a moment that I would not go
all night for this dog you have no idea
you've been here before a couple times
game you have no idea how far I'm
willing to go for this dog you really
really don't know so let's go
[ __ ]
let's see how much you care about your
stupid contrived story where you're just
like trying to make me give up you don't
know how stubborn I am so let's go dogs
yeah yeah dogs dogs lie they lie down in
a nice comfy bed that's what dogs do
they lie down here to comfy bed in a
little comfy bed and I will make sure
this dog gets to that bed if it's the
last thing I do so try me
hey I'm and until done I made one
mistake I played through the whole
goddamn 12-hour games back to that point
you don't think I'll sit here for 12
hours try me [ __ ] I ain't stopping I
know what you want me to do it ain't
happening
never on your life so let Seth everybody
buckle the [ __ ] up because Wiis gonna be
here a long time
I think I see the heart rate and like
the shaking starting so if this game
wants to fool itself all this heavy if
this game wants to fool itself into
being like ah the characters too weak
has to let it go it can lie to itself
like that I won't give up nah no way no
way no hell no how so yeah go ahead and
try to play that game yeah try to play
that game you're just embarrassing
yourself game I don't know if you know
this but this is a shorter walk than I
usually take chica 4 so if you think
that this is trying me in any way you
are so far from the truth I don't even
know how to break it to you you're not
even testing me at this moment you're
not even making me break a sweat this
nothing they're gonna do that thing
where it's like I'm so wimpy I can't go
the distance for my dog yeah right
oh okay okay okay it's okay
easy boy easy I'm here and with you too
let dying dogs lie yeah okay yeah sure
I'm wrong I know how to give advice of a
wall
I give stupid advice oh I think it's
hilariously adorable that any game
thinks that it could out stubborn me
I'll work and pull an all-nighter for
this [ __ ] I don't care you came here
together we're walking out together
that's how it is that's how it is we
came here together we are walking out
together no matter where we're walking
out if we're walking into a grave we're
[ __ ] both walking into that grave
buddy listen I don't care what this game
says if I don't agree to you stop shoot
your dog shoot yourself go away that's a
good boy will you good boy
Oh hold see to leave him know what the
hell I was trying to talk to him
no what are you talking about old
theater leave them I got a dog treat so
maybe I could get to it night little one
let me access my inventory and I'm not
risking pressing any I'm not risking
letting go this w key cuz I know it's
gonna be a dick billy goat you had
attained you had you gave you for a love
in a time like now
not even close it's gonna make me pass
out before it does anything different
getting real hard to see things push a
good boy it's a good boy
don't worry I'd like to think I'm
absorbing your pain into my own body I'm
taking the pain and I'm just I'm
marinating it in myself because
technically I'm bigger than you but I'm
like three to four times bigger than you
so I can hold in twice as much pain as
you so I can take some of it so feel
free to share the load also feel free to
poop at any point you can make yourself
lighter just poop piss all over my arms
I don't care just try to get on the
ground I'll try to avoid it the next
time we come right around the bend again
but I if that would make it lighter not
that I care I mean hold it in if you got
oh if you got your dignity I don't care
my eyes are getting really veiny
it stopped giving voice lines anymore
cuz I've already beaten the game in
terms of voice lines
[Music]
what excuse me excuse me now you're
taking Oh
now you're trying to put text in front
of me to convince me to stop
excuse me game I've already committed to
this
it's obvious you're having second
thoughts about it so why don't you just
give up already because I I have all of
the willpower in the world to make sure
that this dog follows me to the ends of
the earth
yeah you should blame yourself for
making such a lovable dog I'm it's your
fault it's your fault though we're here
I literally don't care if I never see
the end of this game because I will stay
here and then that will be it that'll be
the rest this is where the game ends for
me me walking eternally with my dog
that's just where it's gonna be good
what what the hell what what
[Music]
what
hey get up can I get up hey get up no
better nautilus pull it pull it
no no [ __ ] [ __ ]
what you son-of it you you I knew I knew
it I knew it I knew it you didn't have
enough goddamn guts to let me walk with
that dog to the end of eternity so you
oh oh no good take it away where where
is he where is it come on mama
come on where is he Oh where's this wish
you won't break me you hear me I won't
lose to you whatever
where's bullet wears bullet Oh Oh blame
this game oh no can't go back where's
bullet I don't see bullets body so to be
bullet ain't dead huh
where's bullet oh nice treat loser nerd
where's bullet oh boy where are you
bullet bullet
[Music]
hold it hold it sheriff goddamnit Ellis
I've been trying to reach you for hours
anyway I just wanted to say that we're
dropping this search it's nothing
personal but hey you left him there to
die it's only fair you die alone out
there as well well tough but true you're
right you're right you're right Oh
hello Oh goodbye don't know about
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
and it on its own
uh-huh who's gonna pay
bullet doesn't like him yeah bullet
doesn't like him so I break him whoa
that's a new one
that's different weird hello oh no duh
oh I'm an idiot
uh-uh I'm dumb okay um yeah I didn't
yeah I didn't think about that for some
reason hey what about the camera do I
still have that that doesn't help and
doesn't help at all
I'll do the flashlight ball it wears
bowling
I've got a dog treat with bullets name
on it
[Music]
who are you who do you think you are
yeah out of here oh hi hello tree don't
like I can't take it anymore make it
stop work damn it work damn it okay what
am i doing exactly
oh I'm hunting these babies down okay I
don't know why I'm doing this but uh
lady if you can help me find my dog
Abby great you sure can whoever you are
mysteries lady Oh
bullet what happened to his dog
[Music]
whoo oh okay
okay what if I'd done so what's your
point here what you're trying to say
that you quit before I did is that all
your same block bullet is right here in
my heart oh hey honey
Jess I was in Jesse
well week what did I do
week week I'm trying not to just kill me
already beautiful
what does so you're still struggling huh
what did you do with the kid good kid
that's what you're worried about stupid
little man I could slit your throat and
wear your skin you'll have to work for
that doesn't make any sense
oh no you did this all I did was give
you a choice you chose the dog and now
it's dead it fills you
I filled you now you have nothing now
you already
[Applause]
yes I'm so sorry I was so lost he
trapped in my own mind I tried to reach
you I know and I pushed you away you
couldn't have known what I was going
through I should have told you I will
Alice
Jess please forgive me I don't want to
lose you I can't I I love you so much I
love you too Alice but it's not as easy
as saying sorry
I know but it's a start
[Music]
ray of hope that sounds like a good
achievement that sounds like a good
achievement that sounds pretty good to
me why I did everything you wanted me to
what the hell am I supposed to do now
what I okay well the thing is I didn't I
did not leave bullet mind I did not to
me bullet is alive and well who is doing
real good
I swear if this game doesn't isn't like
rewards me for sticking it out more than
the game could I will be very mad steady
progress the patient seems to be open up
more once some time has passed from the
event the drawing facilitates memory
recollection I was able to put together
a rough timeline at events the children
leave the patients house and enter the
woods he finds a wounded animal in a
snare he is drawn to the disturbance
there's a man while be something happens
this is a repressed memory the patient
leaves the woods and is found by a truck
driver will slowly build up towards the
repressed memories continuing using the
Haverhill method consult with dr. Smith
about aggression as a symptom of anxiety
neurosis okay I'm pretty sure these are
all about me these are very clearly all
about moi be something useful the reveal
[Music]
god
face
oh where did that come from
wait a minute hey I see you all right
I'm coming
wasn't it Peter Philip what's the it
I've forgotten hey I'm gonna barge in
here hope you don't mind my bulb there
we go hello hello perfect I love it I
love it it's perfect
okay so there's a bunch of marks but I
don't know what they do
hey those are locked that's good
all right cool spooky
bears
very spooky huh oh I don't like that I
don't like that I don't like that at all
actually in fact I do not what's up
there
show yourself I'm coming for you all
right okay all right you win this round
well hide-and-seek champion I see how
this is it's awfully spooky up here okay
I don't like this yeah oh hey icky
that's good good thing I went up here I
don't know why I was drawn to this
specifically but good thing I'm up here
okay so I have a funny feeling we're
getting close to the end here but I'm
out of time
captain woods I love that movie I'm out
of time for this particular episode so
I'm gonna continue this in the final
episode unless the final episode is like
five minutes then I'll roll it into this
one sound fair so you'll see you'll
already know the answer to this one for
now thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know anything down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]